well and the other thing is too it like
makes them like shiny like their their
skin it makes it looks plastic because
everything is stretched out the Reality
Skin is meant to be able to stretch and
contract yeah but once you get BOTOX
then you kind of well and what would you
look like when because I would imagine
the average chick doesn't make that much
money you're not going to marry a guy
that makes that much money so what are
you gonna look like when it stops and
the funny thing is people get BOTOX and
they don't go to the gym so think about
that so you're keeping your skin intact
but the muscles underneath are failing
yeah so it's it doesn't make sense